fan the fuel
and the flames and it's fueled it
and if anybody has any doubts about the
potential harmful effects of social
media
the surgeon general yesterday
issued a powerful
report
about the implications of social media
as well as video gaming and other
technologies
on teen mental health
and that's part of the reason we're here
the hearings have shown that social
media in particular big tech
actually
fans those flames with addictive
products and sophisticated algorithms
that can exploit
and profit from children's insecurities
and anxieties
and our mission now is do something
about it
we're here to do more than shake fists
we really are seeking solutions
and we welcome
the voices and the vision of big tech
itself
in that
effort
i
believe that the time for self-policing
and self-regulation is over
some of the big tech companies have said
trust us that seems to be what instagram
is saying in your testimony
but self-policing depends on trust the
trust is gone
what we need now
is independent researchers
objective
overseers
not chosen by big tech but from outside
and strong vigorous enforcement of
standards that stop the destructive
toxic
content that now too often is driven at
kids and
takes them down rabbit holes to dark
places
the day before this hearing instagram
announced a set of
proposals
uh these simple time management and
parental oversight tools should have
they could have been announced
years ago
they weren't and in fact
these changes fall way short of what we
need in my view
many of them are still in testing months
away
the rollouts will be done at some point
in the future we don't know exactly when
and unfortunately
these announced changes
leave
parents
and kids with
no transparency
into the black box algorithms
the 600 pound gorillas in those black
boxes that drive that destructive
and addictive content to children and
teens no effective warning or notice to
parents
when their children are spiraling into
eating disorders
bullying or self-harm
nothing more than the bare minimum
controls
for parents and of course no real
accountability to assure parents and
kids that these safeguards
will work
i'm troubled with the lack of answers on
instagram kids once again this pause
looks more like a public relations
tactic brought on by our hearings just
as these announced changes seem to be
brought on by
these proceedings
announced just hours before your
testimony
and we need
real serious review of those changes
the magnitude of these problems requires
bold
and broad solutions and accountability
which has been lacking so far
facebook's own researchers have been
warning management
including yourself mr missouri for years
about instagram's harmful impacts on
teens mental health and well-being and
the
whistleblower who sat exactly where you
are
told us about those documents about the
research the studies
which showed
that facebook
knew
it did the research it had the studies
but it continued to profit
from the destructive content because it
meant more eyeballs more advertising
more dollars
given those warnings
it seems inexcusable that
facebook waited a decade to begin and
only to begin
figuring out that instagram needed
parental controls in the past two months
this subcommittee
has heard horrifying stories from
countless parents
whose lives and their children's lives
have been changed forever one father
from connecticut
wrote to me about his daughter who
developed severe anxiety in high school
because of constant pressure from
instagram
that pressure became so intense
following her
home from school following her
everywhere she went
going her into her bedroom in the
evening that she attempted suicide
fortunately her parents
stepped in and sought help and found a
recovery program but the experience
continues to haunt her
and her family
facebook's researchers
called this fall into that
kind of dark rabbit hole a perfect storm
that's the quote perfect storm
created by its own algorithm
that exacerbate downward spirals
harmful to teens
again facebook knows about the harm it's
done the research the studies
the surveys repeatedly it knows the
destructive consequences
of the algorithms and designs it knows
teens struggle with addiction and
depression on instagram
but
that data has been hidden like the
algorithms
themselves
just yesterday that surgeon general's
report
provided powerful documentation on how
social media can fan those flames and
fuel the fires of the mental health
crisis that we face among
teen
and it signals that something is
terribly wrong
what really stuns me is the lack of
action in fact just within the last two
months
two months ago
this subcommittee heard testimony from
facebook's global head of safety
ms antigone davis
at that time i showed her
the pro-eating disorder rampant on
instagram i demonstrated through an
experiment how its algorithms will flood
a team
with triggering and toxic messages in
just hours after we created
an account
this was
glorification of being dangerously
underweight tips on skipping meals
images we could not
in good conscious show in this room
it's been two months
so we've repeated our experiment
on monday we created another fake
account for a teenager and followed a
few accounts promoting eating disorders
and again
within an hour
all of our recommendations
promoted
anorexia and
eating disorder
content
two months ago the global head of public
safety for facebook was put on notice by
this
subcommittee
nothing has changed
it's all still happening
and in the meantime more lives have been
broken realized with real families
and futures
and you hear from
yourself
we all
know that
if facebook saw a significant threat to
its growth or ad revenue
it wouldn't wait two months
to take action so why does it take
months for facebook to act
when our kids face danger when time is
not on our side time
is not on our side
so no wonder parents are worried in fact
parents are furious
they don't trust instagram google tick
tock
and
all of their big tech fears and by the
way this is not an issue limited
to instagram or facebook
parents are asking what is congress
doing to protect our
kids
and the resounding bipartisan message
from this committee is
legislation is
coming
we can't rely on trust anymore we can't
rely on self-policing
it's what parents and our children are
demanding
senator blackburn and i are listening to
them as our other members of committee
we are working together
your proposal for an industry body
ask parents yet again to trust us
we'll do it ourselves
but self-regulation relies on that trust
that has been
squandered
we need to make sure that the
responsibility is on big tech to put a
safe product on the market
you can't be allowed to conceal when
products are harming kids so the first
imperative is transparency we need real
transparency into these 800
pound gorilla black box
algorithms and addictive designs
and disclosure has to include
independent qualified researchers who
will then
tell the story to the public
we need to update our children's privacy
laws congress should
pass the bipartisan children's and teens
online privacy
protection act authored by
senator markey who's here today i'm
proud to be working with him on updating
and expanding it parents and children
need more power
and more effective tools to protect
themselves
on
the platform
and that's why senator blackburn and i
are working on a framework work and
we've made good progress
to enable that protection
there really should be a duty of care
the united kingdom has imposed it it's
part of the law there
why not here
that ought to be part of the framework
of legislation that we're considering
section 230 reform
you make a reference to it in your
testimony
the days of absolute broad
unique immunity for big tech are over
and finally enforcement state
authorities
federal authorities law enforcement has
to be rigorous
and strong
so i hope
that
we will begin the effort of working
together
but one way the other
this committee will move forward
and
again i thank you
for being here i thank all of my
colleagues for attending
and i ask uh for remarks by the ranking
member senator blackburn and thank you
senator blumenthal and uh welcome to
everyone we are appreciative
that you are here today mr missouri we
are grateful for your time and for your
testimony i do want to thank
senator blumenthal and his team for the
work this is the fifth hearing
that we have held
dealing with the issues around big tech
and the invasions of privacy the lack of
data security the need for section 230
reforms and looking very directly
at what these platforms social media
platforms the effect the negative and
adverse effect that they are having on
our children
um
i will tell you that today i am just a
little bit frustrated
i i'm frustrated because this is now
the fourth time in the past two years
that we have spoken with someone from
meta as you are now calling yourselves
and i feel like the conversation
continues to repeat itself ad nauseam
and when i go back home to tennessee i
know that the people
there
lots of moms and dads and teachers and
pediatricians
they share this frustration
because they continue to hear from you
that change is coming the things are
going to be different that there are
going to be more tools in the toolbox
the kids are going to be safer online
that privacy is going to be protected
and that data is going to be
secure
but
guess what
nothing
changes
nothing
the chairman just
talked about what happened with miss
davis when she came in and how we
pointed all of this out specifically
of what we had found
and yet yesterday
what happened the exact same thing
so i hope that you appreciate the
frustration that the american public
feels
that they are
they appreciate
what the internet can do
for them
and bringing the world closer but the
applications
that you were pushing forward the social
media the addictive nature the way this
affects children
there is such a frustration that you
turn a blind eye
toward taking responsibility and
accepting
accountability
for
your platform how you are structured
and how you use the data
on these children yesterday at 3 a.m
which is midnight in the silicon valley
you released a list of product updates
that you said would raise the standard
for protecting teens and supporting
parents online
and i'm not sure what hours you all keep
in california but where i'm from
the middle of the night is when you drop
news that you don't want people to see
and maybe you thought that doing it
in this manner would keep members of the
subcommittee from seeing it right away
and from raising concerns because while
i'm sure you know that we fully share
the goal of protecting
kids and teens online what we aren't
sure about
is how the half measures you've
introduced are going to get us to the
point
where we need to be to truly protect
teens and young adults online for
example
we know that social media is an integral
part of teens daily lives according to
the mayo clinic 97 percent of teens
between ages 13 and 17
use
a social media platform
and 45 percent say they are online
almost constantly so while telling teens
to
take a break
might seem helpful on the face of things
it's probably not going to get most
teenagers to stop doing what they're
doing and take a break
educational tools for parents can be
helpful but frankly i'm more concerned
about the things we know kids and teens
are hiding from their parents we know
that facebook and instagram have
encouraged teams to use secondary
accounts and told them to be authentic
and we all remember what it was like to
be a teenager so while parents might
gain some insight into what their teams
do on their main accounts
what do they do about the accounts they
don't even know
exist
the ones that instagram is encouraging
them
to create
and instagram announced in july that it
would default to all teams onto
private accounts when they sign up for
the site yet just yesterday
my team created an account as a 15 year
old girl
and it defaulted to public
so while instagram is touting all these
safety measures they aren't even making
sure
that these safety measures are in effect
for me
this is a case of too little too late
because now there is bipartisan momentum
both here and in the house to tackle
these problems we are seeing with big
tech
as senator blumenthal said
we are working
on children's privacy
online privacy
data security and section 230 reforms
this is
the appropriate time to pass a national
consumer privacy bill as well as
kid-specific legislation to keep miners
safe online we also need to give serious
thought to how companies like facebook
and instagram continue to hide behind
section 230s liability shield when it
comes to content like human trafficking
sex trafficking drug trafficking
despite congress speaking clearly to
this issue when we passed foster and
sesta a few years ago
mr missouri there is a lot of work for
us to do to improve the online
experience and to protect our children
and our grandchildren i think it's best
if we do this together and i look
forward to hearing your ideas and your
testimony today thank you for your
appearance
thanks senator blackman i'm pleased to
introduce adam masari
he spent over 11 years
at meta and oversees all functions of
the instagram app including engineering
product
management and operations mr missouri
the floor is yours
right
apologies oh
my apologies
thank you senator
chairman blumenthal
ranking member blackburn members of the
subcommittee i'm adam moseri and i've
served as the head of instagram since
2018.
and over the last few months the
subcommittee has held a number of
hearings on the safety and well-being of
young people online
this is a critically important topic
as you said in your opening statement
and it's something that we think about
and work on every day at instagram
the internet has changed how we all
communicate
it's changed how we express ourselves
it's changed how we stay connected to
the people that we care about it's also
changed what it's like to be a teenager
teenagers have always spent time with
their friends developed new interests
and explored their identities
today they're doing those things on
platforms like instagram
youtube tick tock and snapchat
i firmly believe that instagram and the
internet more broadly can be a positive
force in young people's lives
i'm inspired every day by teens on
instagram and i'm proud that our
platform is a place
where they can spend time with the
people that they care about
where they can start incredible
movements
where they can find new interests
or they can even turn a passion into a
business
i also know that sometimes young people
can come to instagram dealing with
difficult things in their lives
i believe that instagram can help in
those critical moments it's one of the
things that our research has shown and
to me this is the most important work
that we can do taking on complex issues
like bullying and social comparison and
making changes
now i recognize that many in this room
have deep reservations about our company
but i want to assure you that we do have
the same goal
we all want teens to be safe online
the internet isn't going away and i
believe there's important work that we
can do together industry and policy
makers
to raise the standards across the
internet to better serve and protect
young people
but the reality is that keeping people
safe
is not just about any one company
an external survey just last month
suggested that more teens are using
tiktok and youtube than instagram
this is an industry-wide challenge and
requires industry right solutions and
industry-wide standards
now we have a specific proposal we
believe there should be an industry body
that will determine the best practices
when it comes to what i think are the
three most important questions with
regards to youth safety
how to verify age
how to build age-appropriate experiences
and how to build parental controls
the body should receive input from civil
society from parents and from regulators
the standards need to be high
and the protection is universal
i believe that companies like ours
should have to earn some of their
section 230 protections by adhering to
those standards
and we've been calling for regulation
for nearly three years now and from
where i said there's no area more
important than you safety
that said i understand that developing
policy takes time
so we're going to continue to push
forward on the safety and well-being of
young people online
on age verification we're developing new
technologies to address this
industry-wide challenge
we're creating a menu of options to
allow people to verify that they're old
enough to use instagram that extend
beyond simply relying on an id card
and we're building new technology to
proactively find and remove accounts
belonging to those under the age of 13.
we're also using technology to
understand if people are above or below
the age of 18 so that we can create a
more age-appropriate version of
instagram for them
for example
adults can no longer message people
under the age of 18 that don't follow
them
and as of this week we announce that
people can no longer tag or mention
teens that don't follow them as well
we also provide tools for parents
parents and guardians know what's best
for their teams
and we're launching instagram's first
set of parental controls in march of
next year
allowing them to see how much time their
teens spend on instagram and to set time
limits
we'll also give teens a new option to
notify their parents
if they report someone giving their
parents an opportunity to talk about it
with them
as a father of three i care a great deal
about creating an online world that is
safe for my children and that allows
them to benefit from all the amazing
things the internet has to offer
as ahead of instagram
i recognize the gravity of my role in
making this happen
not only for my kids but for generations
to come
i'm hopeful that we can work together to
reach that goal
thank you
thanks mr missouri i'll take the first
round of questions again we're gonna
do uh five-minute rounds
uh
just uh
a short while ago at our last hearing
tick tock snapchat and ut who
sat at that table and they all committed
to making internal research algorithms
and data sets about their effect on
children and teens available to
independent
researchers
will you commit to doing the same
senator we believe it's important to be
transparent both with about ranking and
algorithms and about data for research
i can commit to you today that we will
provide meaningful access to data so
that third-party researchers can
design their own studies and make their
own conclusions about the effects of
well-being on young people
and on ranking i can commit to do all i
can to explain how ranking works and to
find other ways for us to be transparent
about algorithms will you support a
legal requirement
that independent
overseers and researchers
not only have access to the data sets
but also check
the
way algorithms are driving content
and recommend changes that you will
adopt
senator i'd be happy to have my office
work with you on that i believe that
direction is an important one we do a
number of things in this area already we
provide
information every month on the effects
of our algorithms on removing
problematic content from our system well
you commit to a legal requirement that
the access be provided
and that an independent
separately appointed and
separately funded
body not an industry
body as you've suggested but
an independent overseer and researcher
have that access
senator
on the specifics of how the body works
i'm not a legal expert but yes i think
there should be requirements and
standards for how companies like ours
are transparent about both data and
algorithms because
an industry body is not
government regulation that mark
zuckerberg or
others
at facebook and elsewhere have called
for
an industry body setting standards is
not the same
as an independent one let me ask you
shouldn't children
and parents have the right
to report dangerous material abuse and
get a response get some action because
we've heard harrowing stories from
parents who've tried to report
and have heard no response
my office made a report and got no
response until cnn
made the
report to press relations
shouldn't there be an obligation that
instagram will respond
senator
yes i believe we try and respond to all
reports and if we ever fail to do so
that is a mistake that we should correct
instagram
is addicted
that's the view that
has been repeated again and again and
again by people who are expert
in this field parents know it and for
teens who
see instagram's algorithms
encouraging for example eating disorders
they find it almost impossible to stop
the uk code
restricts instagrams use of addictive
design
legally restricts its use of addictive
design
shouldn't we have a similar role in the
united states
senator respectfully i don't believe the
research suggests that our products are
addictive
research actually shows that on 11 of 12
difficult issues that teens face teens
are struggling said instagram helps more
than harms now we always care about how
people feel about their experiences on
our platform and it's my responsibility
as ahead of instagram to do everything i
can to help keep people safe and we're
going to continue to do so we can debate
the meaning of the word addictive but
the fact is
that teens
who go to the platform find it difficult
maybe sometimes impossible
to stop and part of the reason is that
more content is driven to them
to keep them on the site to aggravate
the emotions that
are so seductive and ultimately
addictive
the uk recognizes it
by imposing that
design restriction
the same ought to be done
in the united states let me ask you will
you commit to make the pause on
instagram
kids permanent in other words
stop developing
a site for
an app for children under 13.
senator
the idea of building a version of
instagram for 10 to 12 year olds was
trying to solve a problem
the idea being that we know that 10 to
12 year olds are online they want to use
platforms like instagram and it's
difficult for companies like ours to
verify age
for those that are so young they don't
yet have an id
the hope was to always or the plan was
to always make sure that no
child between 10 and 12 had access to
any version of instagram even one that
was designed for them without their
parents consent and so what i can commit
to today is that no child between the
ages of 10 or 12 should we ever manage
to
build
instagram for 10 to 12 year olds will
have access to that without their
explicit parental consent
i have more questions my time is expired
i thank you for
answering my questions miss missouri
senator blackburn
thank you mr chairman staying on
instagram kids
for a moment i knew you were doing
research into eight-year-olds
and pulling together data on
eight-year-olds and i assume
and that that was in relation to
instagram kids so are you still doing
research on children under age 13.
sorry making sure the mic is on senator
i don't believe we ever did any research
with eight-year-olds for instagram kids
and no neither are we doing that today
we've entirely paused the project
okay
and then if you were to completely
remove that project who would make that
decision
senator it was my decision to pause
instead of grandkids and so you would it
would be your decision to just do away
with it
senator
i'm responsible for instagram so yes it
would be my decision okay let's talk
about jane doe versus facebook
is senator what
jane doe versus facebook apologies okay
i assume you can't get into the details
of that because the supreme court is
still deciding whether or not to take
that case
but the petition which alleges that
facebook enabled the trafficking of a
minor on its platform really raises some
very serious questions
and concerns about what we're seeing and
how people are using
instagram so do you prohibit
known sex offenders from creating
instagram accounts
senator
human trafficking
and any exploitation of children is
abhorrent and we don't allow it on our
platforms okay do you require minors
to
uh link their accounts to a parent or
guardian's account
senator
if you're over at the age of 13 you can
sign up for an instagram account but we
do believe that parental controls are
incredibly important which is why we're
launching our first version in march of
next year okay you know um
yes
the controls are going to be vitally
important but an industry group is not
going to give the controls that are
needed and
probably not even an independent group
that is why we'll do something with
federal statute
also i think it would be interesting to
know how many people that are in human
trafficking sex trafficking and drug
trafficking that have been indicted or
convicted that were using instagram
could you all provide that number for us
senator i'd be happy to talk to the team
and get back that would be that would be
excellent
my staff created an instagram account
for a 15 year old girl and it defaulted
to public i mentioned that earlier
isn't the opposite supposed to happen
and have you considered turning off the
public option altogether for minor
accounts
senator i appreciate the question i
learned of that just this morning it
turns out that we though we default
those under the age of 16 to private
accounts for the vast majority of
accounts who are created which are
created on android and ios we have
missed that on the web and we will
correct that quickly
okay also when they created this account
it defaulted to
this statement include your account when
recommending similar accounts people
might want to follow
is this a feature that should remain on
by default for minors
senator we think it's important that no
matter what your age it's easy for you
to find accounts that you're interested
in
even if you're under 18.
senator i believe teenagers too have
interests and that should be easy for
them to find those majors have interest
yes but what we're trying to address are
the adverse and negative effects that
are happening to children because
they are on your platform
can adults not labeled as suspicious by
you still find follow and message minors
senator if your account is private if
someone follows you you have to approve
it so adults can
ask to follow you but you have the
decision or the ability to decide
whether or not they're allowed to okay
in your testimony you said you removed
more than 850 000 accounts because they
did not meet your minimum age
requirement
these accounts were disabled because the
users did not provide identification
showing that they were at least 13 years
old so
why did you say you didn't want to know
when jojo siwa
said she had been on instagram since she
was eight years old is that your general
attitude
toward kids who are on your platform
absolutely not senator we invest
a lot to try to identify those under the
age of 13 and whenever we find them
at that moment when you responded to her
that you did not want to know why didn't
you use that as a teaching moment
senator
i would say it was a missed opportunity
indeed it was a mis opportunity and it
sends the wrong message
it looked as if you were encouraging
kids that want to be online stars to get
on earlier and to build their audience
this is a part of our frustration
with you with instagram and with these
platforms thank you mr chairman thanks
senator blackburn senator klobuchar
thank you
mr missouri i'm looking at this from a
perspective of parents
and i guess i'll talk to parents since
so many of them have told me
that they have done everything they can
to try to get their kids off your
product kids who are addicted at age 10
and they are scared for their kids they
want their kids to do their homework and
not get addicted to instagram and yet we
then find out
that what your company did was to
increase your marketing budget to try to
woo more teams from 67 million in 2018
to 309
million dollars focused on kids
this year
and so when i hear you're going to
suddenly with all your technological
wizards develop some kind of new way to
check to see if really young kids are on
there you could have been spending this
money 390 million dollars to do that for
years you have the money to do it
i think that we are and diametrically
oppose goals the goals of parents out
there and the goals of your company
our kids aren't cash cows and that is
exactly what's been going on because
when you look at the marketing budget
and you look at what your companies has
done it's to try to get more and more of
them on board and when i look at your
your company's quotes from one document
you
not you personally but your company
viewed losing teen users as a quote
existential threat whereas parents are
viewing their kids addictions to your
product and other products as its
existential threat to their families so
my first question is is that in fact the
truth that you've been increasing money
advertising money uh to woo more teen
kids onto your platform
no no i don't believe those statistics
are correct we increased our overall
marketing budget between last year and
this year but it was not
i think you characterized it as the
majority of it was focused on teens and
that's not true okay so
do you view the kids as a feeder way for
people to get into your product have you
not have you not done things to get more
teenagers interested in your product are
you not worried about losing them to
other platforms you better tell the
truth you're under oath
absolutely senator senator we try and
make instagram as
relevant as possible for people of all
ages including teams teens do amazing
things on instagram every day but we
also invest i believe more than anyone
else and keeping people including teens
safe we will spend
around 5 billion this year alone and we
have over 40 000 people working on
safety integrity at the company um and
do you think three hours a day is an
appropriate amount of time for kids to
spend on instagram
senator
i'm asking this because just when you
put out those new rules that was an
option for parents three hours a day is
that a good use of kids time
senator
i appreciate the question and it was in
your safety tools that you just put out
there the first option given to kids
to parents was three hours a day
senator i i have them can i put them on
the record sorry
it's your chair thank you if i may
senator i'm a parent and i can
understand that parents have concerns
about how much screen time their kids
have i think that is i think every
parent feels that way i ultimately think
that it's apparent
that a parent knows best what's best for
their teen so the appropriate amount of
time
should be a decision by a parent about
the specific team
if one parent wants to set that limit at
10 minutes and another parent wants us
to hit that limit at three hours who am
i to say that they don't know what's
best for their children
and do you believe your company has
invested enough in identifying uh that
young children are not on the platform
when you know that they're not supposed
to be on there and making sure you're
registering and using all your
technology not to just increase your
profits but to make sure the kids aren't
on there you think you've done enough
senator
two things one yes i believe that we've
invested more than anyone else but i
also believe that it's still a very
challenging industry-wide issue i think
there's a number of things that we can
do at the industry level to better
verify age
specifically
i believe it would be much more
effective to have age verification at
the device level have a parent who gives
their 14 year old advice
tell the phone that their child is 14 as
opposed to having every app and there's
millions of apps out there trying to
verify age on their own that should
happen at the device level
we understand that might not happen or
that might take time and in the meantime
we're going to invest heavily in getting
more sophisticated and how we identify
the age of people under the age of 18.
and is it true that someone in your
company said that it was an existential
threat if you lost teen users
senator
i don't is that not is that true or not
because we have a document that said
that senator i assume that's true
okay so you understand what we're
thinking up here when it's our job to
protect kids and we have parent after
parent calling our office emailing us
one of the parents likened to me that it
was like a water faucet
going off and it was overflowing and
she's sitting there with a mop trying to
figure out how to use all of the tools
you give them that she can't figure out
how to use so i think at some point the
accountability is on you guys and that
means everything from the privacy bills
to expanding the child protections
online to the competition policy because
maybe if we had actual competition in
this country instead of
meta owning you and owning
most of the platforms and most of the um
on the the back and forth for kids maybe
we could have another platform developed
that would have the privacy protections
uh that you have not been able to
develop in terms of keeping teens off
your platform that aren't even old
enough to be on there so that's what i
think some food for thought for all of
you is the opposition to some of the
competition policy capitalism
pro-capitalism ideas that we have over
in judiciary and i'll hand it back to
our chair
thank you senator klobuchar thanks for
your work uh your leadership on this
issue here and on the judiciary
committee
where we're on the
subcommittee on antitrust which you
chair
i will ask a couple of questions because
we have a vote ongoing so a number of my
colleagues will be
returning
from the floor
uh you know your suggestion
for
tech companies to earn
section 230
protection has a certain appeal
to me since i'm the author of the earn
it act along with senator graham it's
also the concept
that underlies other proposals that
we've made
but that's not
government regulation
uh
so the question is will you support
the uk's
children's code
that instagram has to obey
in the uk
shouldn't kids in
the united states
have protection as good as the
kids in uk enjoy
absolutely senator a few quick things
one is i believe that is the age
appropriate design
for getting the last letter of the
acronym um and i believe it's
something that we support and we support
safety standards for kids everywhere
including here in the u.s and also if
you would indulge me for a minute like
to clarify that my proposal is yes an
industry body
that sets standards for youth safety
with input from civil society
from policymakers and from parents but
one that once those standards are
proposed they would be approved by
policymakers like yourself
and i also believe that
policymakers or regulators should
make the decision of whether or not any
individual company like mine is adhering
to those standards so it's not simply
suffering then enforce them bring
lawsuits see
damages
senator
we believe that a strong incentive would
be to tie section some of the section
230 protections to adherence and that
could be a decision by
regulators
so
would the attorney general of the united
states or the attorney general of a
state like connecticut where i was
attorney general have the power to
enforce
those standards senator we believe in
enforcement specifically how to
implement that enforcement is something
that we would like to work with your
office on and other offices well that's
a simple yes or no enforceability
has to be part of your proposal
senator i agree enforceability is
incredibly important without enforcement
it's just words so you think that the
attorney general of the united states
could enforce those standards which
means they would be written in the
statute
senator i don't know
because i'm not a legal expert expert if
the best way to enforce it would be with
the attorney general but in general i
think it should happen at the federal
level and it's something that i'd be
happy to have my team work with you
favor private rights of action so
individuals who were harmed could bring
an action against
meta senator i believe that it's
important that companies like ours are
held accountable to high standards but i
believe the most important way or the
most effective way of doing so is to
define
industry standards
and best practices at the federal level
ideally and to seek enforcement as you
suggest these are really yes or no
questions
they're pretty clear
and i know you are knowledgeable about
them so i hope you will answer them
more clearly
in
the answers that you provide in writing
i'm going to yield yeah
i just and i can do this on the record
but i did want to since you um
denied this idea that the marketing
budget went from 67 million to 390
million and that much of the budget was
allocated to wooing teams that was
reported on by the new york times from
internal documents from your company so
do you still deny that this is the fact
senator
occasionally there are reports that are
inaccurate in this case i believe that
report or that article said that the
majority of our budget was focused on
teens and i
know for a fact that that was not the
case much of the budget is that
accurate senator i don't remember often
could you give me the number of what
percentage of the budget was focused on
teens you must as a business be able to
break it down that way so that would be
helpful i'll ask that in writing i'd be
happy to follow up okay thank you
senator markey
thank you mr chairman um
you know thanks to uh
your leadership mr chairman we have
francis hogan who
has told us quite clearly
that 32 percent of teen girls say that
when they feel bad about their bodies
um
instagram makes them feel worse
and six percent of american teen users
trace their desire to kill themselves
to instagram
that's your own research mr osari yet
faced with these frightening findings
did facebook back off its efforts to
target children no
just the opposite
facebook pursued plans to launch a
version of the platform for even younger
users
instagram kids
and that is appalling mr mosari i'm glad
facebook
has heeded my calls and paused these
plants but you have since publicly
doubled down on instagram kids and said
it is quote the right thing to do
your statement makes crystal clear that
self regulation is not an option
for
parents and children in the united
states of america
instagram sees a dollar sign when it
sees kids parents should see a stop sign
when it sees instagram
mr mossari do you support
my bipartisan legislation with senator
blumenthal senator cassidy senator
dolumas to update the children's online
privacy protection act and give
and 15 year olds control over their data
yes or no senator respectfully
it's important that we're clear what the
research actually shows
any loss of life to suicide or to
anything out any other reason
is a tragedy but that was six percent
numbers inaccurate it was one percent of
teens would trace their thoughts back
now anybody feeling worse about
themselves is something that we take
incredibly seriously now you ask if i
support the specific act that you're
proposing i do strongly support federal
regulation not industry regulation when
it comes to youth safety
that said if you move the age from 13 to
16 we know that 14 and 15 year olds also
want to be online they also can lie
about their age and you're going to make
the challenge of age verification even
more difficult
that said i do believe that 13 isn't a
magic number people's needs as they grow
up evolve and we should build
age-appropriate experiences based on
children's age so will you will you give
13 to 15 year olds
um the um the right
to have all of their information
expunged
senators being gathered online do you
support legislation that would give
parents and children the ability to have
their records expunged senator you can
already delete your account and all of
your data you should have that right
whether or not you're a teacher what
would you support national legislation
that mandates that each parent and child
be given the ability to expunge it
would you support legislation to do that
make it mandatory senator i would resp i
would support legislation that required
companies like ours
to allow people to delete their data yes
yep okay and and and just to make that a
permanent protection that's on the books
would you support legislation to ban
targeted ads
towards children
senator it's teens and children senator
we believe that anyone should always
have an age-appropriate experience on
instagram or on any social platform and
then extends to ads
we have different rules for ads on
instagram and on facebook we only allow
advertisers to target based on age
based on gender and based on location
and we don't allow certain types of ads
things like weight loss ads
and dating ads
for those under the age of 18 or
alcohol-related ads for those under the
age of 21.
so do you support legislation that would
ban
a
targeting
of ads to children yes or no
senator i believe it's valuable for ads
to be relevant but i do believe that
some measures need to be taken to keep
children safe which is why i would
support something in the direction of
what we do which is to limit the
targeting abilities of platforms
well again
yes and no man data no no mandate that's
that's the question it's it's it's
exactly why we have to make sure that uh
facebook and instagram don't reserve the
right to uh to be able to target these
kids yes or no
senator
i'm trying to be specific about what i
would support which is
what we build which is limited targeting
options
uh would would um all right again would
i just keep coming back to um the fact
that
your answers are
uh are too vague to make it possible for
us to make these uh decisions in a in
an informed legislative way and to do so
in the very near future which is what i
think we have to do
uh and uh the chilling truth
unfortunately continues just to be that
in the absence of
regulation that big tech has become a
threat to our democracy our society
and to the children in our country uh
and let's just be clear facebook which
owns instagram opposes regulation uh
your idea of regulation is
uh an industry group creating standards
that your company follows uh that's
self-regulation uh that status quo uh
and uh that just won't cut it
uh post the revelations that this
subcommittee has uh made public uh we do
need laws we need laws passed by this
body uh we have to ban targeted ads we
have to make sure that that is the law
in our country uh and uh everything that
this subcommittee has unveiled continues
to make that a necessity including the
testimony that you are delivering today
thank you mr trump thanks senator
marquis senator baldwin
so i
i
sorry i missed just a segment as i went
over to vote and it may have come up um
because uh this is work i did with
senator klobuchar uh but
i joined uh senators klobuchar and
capito in writing to meta for more
information about how instagram is
combating eating disorder content
and the harms it brings to users
particularly young people in response to
our question about how the platform is
working to remove this content meta
indicated that it uses a combination i'm
quoting now from the letter a
combination of reports from our
community human review and artificial
intelligence close quote
to find and take down material that
violates your terms of service
the response further notes that there
are more than fifteen 000 human
reviewers on staff
i also
met
with francis haugen the former facebook
employee whose disclosures has spurred
this series of hearings and when i asked
her about what more instagram could do
to remove
content like this
content glorifying eating disorders
she argued that more human review is
really the key
according to her many community reports
simply are not investigated and
artificial intelligence cannot
successfully identify patterns networks
and distribution points for problematic
content
given that meta's platforms according to
your own data have
3.6 billion monthly active users
the
15 000 reviewers would seem to pale in
comparison to the amount of content
those 3.6 billion monthly active users
could
could post
so do you agree that more human
reviewers will help you move more
successfully
at
removing
problematic content more quickly and if
so
will your company commit to
strengthening its investment in human
review
senator thank you for the question
we have over 40 000 people human
reviewers and otherwise and engineers
who work on safety and integrity i mean
investing about five billion dollars
this year
in at a high level
people are better at nuance and
technology is often better at scale
i think the most effective thing we can
do not only for eating disorder content
which is tragic and a complicated
societal issue
is to invest more particularly on the
technology side but in both and we're
going to continue to do so um
let me ask i know that this hearing is
focused mostly on youth and harmful
but how many in how many countries
is instagram available
senator instagram is available in over
70 languages i unfortunately don't know
the number of countries off the top of
my head but i'd be happy to get back to
you with that number okay so 70
languages that's the point i was going
to get to
um of those 40 000 or 15 000 which is
what was in the i think the letter
response um
how
many are language specific sort of
monitoring content in
each of those 70 languages
thank you senator actually i misspoke
we review content in 70 languages we
have even more languages that we people
speak that use instagram and we're
always looking to increase the number
that we cover i apologize for the
mistake okay so there are gaps then in
terms of uh human review in those areas
senator we're always looking to improve
not only through language coverage but
through
building more accurate classifiers
through
improving the efficiency of our
reviewers
because it helps keep people more safe
i may have some follow-ups uh with
regard to that that are are uh more
specific but
we also all know that there is
tremendous social pressure for kids to
utilize social media platforms and
services and while it is the industry
standard to block or restrict access to
those younger than 13 we know that
younger teens and tweens are still
signing up for social media accounts
um i appreciate that your company
decided to press pause on its
proposed service focused on younger kids
earlier this year
i understand from your announcement
yesterday that metta is looking to
introduce new parent controls and other
tools for instagram
in the coming months
but i'm concerned about what you are
doing today to keep kids under 13 off
the platform so
tell me a little bit more about what
you're doing to strengthen age
verification
and why given the problems of which
you're already well aware uh with
instagram and meta's experience with uh
other services focused on younger kids
like messenger kids
ha why have you waited to institute more
parental controls or other steps
protecting young
young users
senator on the parental controls
question
i believe
as a parent it's going to be more
responsible to develop an
age-appropriate version of instagram for
those under 13. but i paused that
project and i took
the exact work they were building which
was parental controls because no one was
going to have access unless they had
their parents consent and we pivoted
that to teens because 13 isn't a magical
number now you also asked how do we
verify the age of those under 13
it's difficult given that young people
of that age don't have an id in most
countries
we build what we call classifiers which
try to predict age and then we ask
people to prove their age if it looks
like they might be too young we look at
things like
you know in certain countries you know
sweet 16 is a cultural norm here in the
u.s and so we look for do people say
that on someone's birthday does that
line up with the age they set
and we get better over time as we get
more
signals
but it's i want to be very clear it's
not perfect which is why i believe
there are better industry-wide ways to
solve age verification because it really
is an industry challenge it is not
unique to facebook or to instagram
thank you chairman uh blumenthal will be
back from his vote in a moment and we're
going to be starting our second round we
have some other members that are coming
for their first round in the meantime i
want to return to a question i ask you
about
those that are human traffickers sex
traffickers drug traffickers their
utilization of your site now i know that
in
2020
you sent over 21 million sex abuse
images on your platform
um
facebook sent these
and
you sent these to nick mc so i thank you
for doing that
that's the right thing to do i'm
interested to know whether these child
exploitation images and reports
if in your reports do you include
traffickers and do you include
those violations
when you make that report to nick mick
with these images
senator i'd have to check on that
specific and get back to you but we do
allow you to report
an image or photo for violating any of
our standards and you can see how well
we are at reducing the prevalence of
those problems in our
concern get back to us and let us know
if you are also reporting
these individuals that are posting and
sharing
these sexual abuse images of children
senator you're recognized for five thank
you madam chair uh thanks for holding
today's hearing the lack of transparency
from big tech companies and the effect
these companies have on consumers is
concerning
to the public and rightfully so because
of the secrecy with which big tech
protects their algorithms and content
moderation practices we have little idea
how these companies use algorithms
to amplify or suppress content or how
they can affect the behavior of users
without their knowledge
tomorrow the communications subcommittee
on which i serve as ranking member will
take a closer look at the effects of
this persuasive technology and i look
forward to hearing from the panel about
the details of how algorithms and
artificial intelligence are designed and
deployed
on internet platforms to manipulate
users
as well as the bigger picture about what
the future might hold for us when
corporations and governments know more
information about each of us than we
know about ourselves
we must find ways to improve more
transparency and accountability into the
algorithms deployed on internet
platforms that select the content that
billions of people see every day
since hearing from the facebook
whistleblower we now have more insight
into instagram and facebook's troubling
practices with regard to how it uses
algorithms and in my view
it's long past time for congress to
enact legislation to ensure that these
companies are held accountable
there's also bipartisan support for
shedding more light on the secret of
content moderation processes big tech
users use as i should say and to provide
consumers more options when engaging
with internet platforms which is why
i've introduced two bipartisan bills to
address these issues the pact act and
the filter bubble transparency act and i
look forward in the time that i have to
uh discussing those issues with you
today mr masari and let me start by just
asking does instagram use persuasion
persuasive technology meaning technology
that is designed to change people's
attitudes and behaviors
senator i've worked on ranking and
algorithms for years and that's not how
we work we use ranking to try and
connect people with
the friends that they find meaningful
and we use them to try and keep people
safe
the wall street journal revealed that
instagram often ignored warnings about
the harmful impact the platform had on
users particularly young girls
with that being said do you believe
consumers should be able to use
instagram without being manipulated by
algorithms that are designed
to keep them hooked on the platform
and would you support giving consumers
more options when engaging on
instagram's platform for instance
providing consumers a fee that's not
being fed to them by algorithms or that
is in a chronological order
senator
i believe it's important that people
have control of their experience so yes
i would support giving people the option
to have a chronological fee
on the issue of section 230 reform
senator schatz and i have introduced
legislation that would among other
things require
platforms like instagram to provide for
more due process to users regarding
their moderation
and censorship practices and submit
public transparency reports about
content that has been removed or
de-emphasized
do you believe this provision would help
build trust with instagram's users
senator we believe in more transparency
and accountability and we believe in
more control that's why we're currently
working on a version of a chronological
feed that we hope to launch next year
that's why we provide a number of ways
for you to see how content moderation
works on the platform so for instance
today you can go to the account center
i believe it's called account status and
see any of your content that has been
taken down and that's why we're working
on more ways to give people more control
over their experience and create more
transparency about instagram works
do you believe that algorithm
explanation or algorithm transparency
are appropriate policy responses
i believe very strongly in algorithmic
transparency i think it'd be hard for
you to find someone who's tried as much
to explain how ranking works there's a
number of ways to be transparent i think
in some cases the most effective is to
look at the output of algorithms like we
do in our community guidelines
enforcement report and in other cases
it's more appropriate to explain how
they work instead of releasing millions
of lines of code apologies
and could you just elaborate a little
bit on you talk about
creating giving consumers a feed that's
not being fed them by an algorithm
or that is in a chronological order you
said that you're going to implement that
uh that policy beginning next year how
do you came to that decision
and
sort of more specifically what the dates
uh for that implementation and maybe if
you could elaborate a little bit on just
exactly what that might look like
absolutely senator so we've been focused
for a few years now on how to give
people more control over their
experience
one idea that we've experimented with
publicly is called favorites where you
can pick a subset of people you want to
have show up at the top of feed
another we've been working on for months
now is a chronological version of
instagram
i wish i had a specific month to tell
you right now but right now we're
targeting the first quarter of next year
okay
and we would like to um take what you're
proposing to do and codify it and that's
what the filter bubble act does thank
you man
senator lujan you're recognized thank
you very much you're blackburn and
i want to thank everyone for calling
this important hearing as well to our
chair and to our ranking member
tomorrow i'll also be convening a
hearing titled disrupting dangerous
algorithms
addressing the harms of persuasive
technology
in the communications medium broadband
subcommittee where we'll discuss
legislative solutions to online
amplification of content that spreads
misinformation
threatens the mental and physical
well-being of our children and
promotes
extremism
one of the lines of questions that i had
today based on
questions that came before
from other colleagues earlier
in this
important hearing
lies around
data retention and deletion and i think
there was a line of questioning even now
from
one of my colleagues as well
does instagram have in
place practices
to abide by the principle of data
minimization especially for sensitive
personal information
yes senator can you
provide those to the committee
senator i'd be happy to follow up with
that
that's a yes
senator yes i'll i'll get the exact
details on what we do and follow up with
the commission how long does instagram
store data related to what websites
users visit
and what internal links they click from
inside the app
senator i apologize i do not know that
offhand but again i'd be happy to get
back to you with the specifics there do
you know how long
instagram stores location information
for a user
senator
if you post a photo that has a location
it'll say that location on that photo so
that'll be stored for as long as that
photo is up in other cases i assume
we have retention policies that are
quite short we'll get back to you with
the specifics but it'll depend on the
usage of location data when was the last
time instagram reviewed and updated its
data decision
deletion
and retention policies
senator we operate as one company so it
would be for both instagram and facebook
so we would know there wouldn't be a
specific retention policy for instagram
i don't know the last time the policies
were specifically updated but i can tell
you that we're constantly working on
privacy making sure that we can do more
to empower people to protect their own
data and making sure that we're
compliant with the increasing number of
privacy regulations around the world
would you support federal policy
legislation that enforces data retention
limits and data deletion requirements
senator
not only would we support that we
believe it's important for there to be
privacy regulation here in the us and
that's something that we've been very
public about for years now when users
request to download their data from
instagram
are users given all information that the
company holds on them including
assumptions that the company
has about them based on their behavior
senator when you download your data we
give you everything
that is associated with you as far as i
know but i want to make sure i double
check that
there are certain instances
where actually i can't think of any
exceptions but i'll get back to you so
the other way that i would ask that
question that maybe it requires
follow-up is
is there any information that instagram
does not share with users when they
request their data
senator we do our best to share all the
data or all your data when you ask to
download your data as
we add new features we add them to what
we call download your data to make sure
that you have all the data
instagram has the
option for users to request to delete
their data that instagram holds is that
correct
yes and if you delete your account you
can delete your data if you request it
is there any data that instagram holds
from a user after a user
deletes their information
not that i know of senator no is that
something you can get back to me on as
well
absolutely but i can also assure you
that we do all we can to delete all your
data if you ask us to
do otherwise would be
incredibly problematic
i i appreciate that there was a question
that i asked mr zuckerberg
back in
2017 about facebook's collection
behavior
about non-users
to which he responded to me
that facebook did not collect non-user
information
on facebook about a week later released
a correction to that where
that mr zuckerberg must have been
mistaken or had a lapse in how he
responded
to that particular question
but nonetheless i really want to get to
the bottom of that especially with the
rampant collection of data from
individuals as well
and then the last question i'm sure that
i'll submit into the record because i'm
out of time now is
the work that has to be done in
non-english language
disinformation and misinformation
it's a huge problem
i think it's important for
facebook for instagram and meta i get
confused with
which term i should be using here with
rebranding i guess i'm not so good with
with it but i'm comfortable with any
term you would prefer that um
that
we're able to get disaggregated data
as we requested in this hearing
from a facebook witness
and we still have not been responded to
and i think it's very important for the
committee's wishes to be respected which
were done in a bipartisan way
senator i appreciate that point since we
talked about that the other day i've
started to look into that there are a
number of ways we might be able to break
out data around our community standards
enforcement policy it's possible
one possibility is
what language the content is in another
possibility is what language the person
who sees that content speaks another
possibility is what country and so we're
going to get back to you on what we
think is the most efficient and that's
responsible thing we can do in this
space and i'll personally make sure that
we do that and get back to you promptly
thanks senator lujan senator lee
mr moseri does instagram advocate
weight loss or plastic surgery for
teenage girls under the age of 18
sorry senator i apologize i missed the
second word in your question do you have
a what does instagram advocate for does
it recommend weight loss or plastic
surgery for girls under the age of 18.
absolutely not we don't recommend
an eating disorder related content to
people of every age very glad to hear
that
um
i beg to differ here
leading up to this hearing i've heard of
about a lot of
complaints from people across utah
and
and elsewhere
uh who have told me about inappropriate
content available through the explore
page um on instagram
um
available specifically to children and
so i was encouraged to see
to look into it myself so i had my staff
create
a
a a
a fictitious 13 year old account
for a fictitious 13 year old girl the
explore page
yielded fairly benign results at first
when all we did was create the account
knowing that it was a 13 year old girl
but
instagram
also provided that same account for this
fake 13 year old
that included some recommendations
a list of recommendations of accounts
that we should follow including
multiple celebrities and influencers so
we followed the first count
uh the the first account that was
recommended by instagram which happened
to be
a very famous female celebrity
now after following that account we went
back to the explore page and the content
quickly changed you see right at first
all that came up when we opened up the
account were some fairly benign
hair styling videos but that's not what
we saw
after
we followed this account the account
that was recommended by instagram itself
and it expanded into all sorts of stuff
including
content that was full of unrealistic
standards for women including plastic
surgery and commentary on women's height
content that could be detrimental to the
self-image of any 13 year old girl
and
if you need
any kind of evidence on the kinds of
harms that this can produce you can you
can look to the report that i recently
issued through my
joint economic committee
team uh specifically on this topic last
week
so mr moser
why did following
instagram's top
recommended account for a 13 year old
girl
cause our explore page
to go from
showing
really innocuous things like hair
styling videos
to
content that promotes body dysmorphia
sexualization of women and content
otherwise unsuitable for a 13 year old
girl what happened
senator
eating disorder
related content and eating disorders
more broadly are very complicated and
difficult to change society without and
they're complicated enough without
a
a social media site recommending it
senator
we know that a lot of i've personally
spoken to teens and multiple countries
around the world that use instagram to
get support when suffering from things
like eating disorders we absolutely do
not want any content that promotes
eating disorders on our platform we do
our best to remove it i believe and i'll
get back to the specifics that it's
roughly five in every 10 000 things
viewed and i my responsibility as the
head of instagram is to get to that
number to as close to zero as possible
but we believe that every company
snapchat tick tock youtube should be
public like we are about exactly what
the prevalence of important content
problems are on our platform right i i
get that
and and i can only take your word for it
here
i i understand what you're saying about
the overall numbers that's not how it
appeared on this account that's not how
it happened at all it was hair styling
videos and innocuous stuff one minute
the next minute after we followed a
famous female celebrity it changed and
it went dark fast it was not five and
one thousand or five and ten thousand
it was rampant but the thing that gets
me is
what changed was following this female
celebrity account and that female
celebrity account was recommended to
this 13 year old girl
so why are you recommending that
somebody follow a site
with the understanding that by doing
that you're exposing that girl to all
sorts of other things that are not
suitable for any child
senator i appreciate the question
because it is an incredibly important
and difficult space
if some if we recommended something that
we shouldn't have i i'm accountable for
that i'm the head of instagram
but you said a second ago you have to
take my word for it and i don't believe
you should
our first community standards
enforcement report sorry we've been
doing it for years but this next quarter
this quote we're in right now is going
to be
independently audited by ernst young and
we're committed to doing independent
audits going forward that's great and
i've independently audited it myself and
what i'm saying to you is i'll take your
word for it as to the five and one
thousand five and ten thousand point
what i'm saying is it was decidedly not
five and one thousand or five and ten
thousand on this page for this poor
unsuspecting albeit fake
thirteen-year-old girl senator that's a
concern look my uh my i'm running i'm
running out of time
but i'm also running out of patience
from a company that has told us over and
over and over again we're so concerned
about your children we're so concerned
we're we're commissioning a blue ribbon
study to be done or we're doing a review
and stuff like this is still happening
meanwhile
the the tech transparency project uh tdp
recently conducted another experiment
uh it demonstrated how miners can use
their instrument instagram accounts
to search for prescription and illicit
drugs and connect with drug dealers in
fact according to tdp
it only took two clicks
two clicks to find drug dealers on that
platform
so
why are children's accounts even allowed
to search for drug content to begin with
much less allowed to do so in a way that
leads them to a drug dealer in two
clicks
senator
accounts
selling drugs or any other regulated
goods are not allowed on the platform
apparently they are senator respectfully
i don't think you can take one or two
examples and indicate that that is
indicative of what happens on the
platform more broadly which is why
and i want to be clear here two clicks
it only took two clicks senator
i'm not familiar with that specific
report i'm more than happy to look into
it i do want to be clear though because
i've been talking about the consumer
sorry the community standards
enforcement report a lot and i know it
sounds like numbers and i know behind
every one of those numbers is a person
who's experiencing something difficult
so i don't want to sound callous in any
way so if there's room for us to improve
i embrace that that's why we invest more
than i believe anybody else 5 billion
this year over 40 000 people that's why
we believe in industry standards and
industry accountability and that's why
we are calling on the entire industry
youtube tick tock snapchat to come
together to set industry standards that
are approved by regulators like here in
the u.s in order to make the internet
more safer for not only kids online but
for everyone
there's a movie
monty python on the search for the holy
grail
there's
a big fight
somebody concludes
the discussion by saying look let's
let's not bicker and argue about who
killed who here
i
i think we have to reach the point where
we realize some real bad stuff is
happening
and um
you're the new tobacco whether you like
it or not and you've got to stop selling
the tobacco
in quotation marks
the kids don't let them have it don't
give it to them thank you thanks senator
lee senator sullivan
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
uh
holding this
important hearing and the series of
hearings that you and
the ranking member have been holding um
mr marsha
mars said
have you
read
the surgeon general's report that he
issued yesterday protecting
youth mental health
senator
i've started to read it i haven't quite
finished it from what i've read so far
it makes it clear that teens in this
country are struggling particularly with
let me um i'll i'll get into it a little
bit i i yes senator i agree very
sobering sobering reading
it mentions in 2021
emergency room visits for suicide
attempts by adolescent girls are up 51
51
i mean
that's just
shocking and
the surgeon general said our obligation
is to act it's not just medical it's
moral
so the way i've
read it it's kind of a witch's brew
of two things that are driving
so much of these horrendous statistics
related to mental health and suicide
it's been the pandemic
and the negative impacts of social media
um one of the
that's in the report
one of the
recommendations from the surgeon general
is limiting social media usage do you
agree with that
senator
i'll answer that question but first i
want to be clear that i don't believe
the research shows that social media is
driving the rise in suicides what wait
why do you think the surgeon general the
united states who just issued a 53 page
report
on mental health and teen suicides
said that we should limit social media
to help get out of this crisis
senator
from what i've read of the surgeon
general's report so far it's about a
number of different issues not just
suicides so to make a connection between
one problem that he talks about and one
of the recommendations he makes i think
is a bit of a leap let me ask my
question again the surgeon general of
the united states
makes us one of his recommendations to
address what clearly is a
mental health crisis
for teenagers particularly teenage girls
in america one of his recommendations
is to limit
social media
usage
so do you agree with it
senator two things
one answer the question i'm senator i
believe
parents should be able to set limits for
their children because i believe a
parent knows best which is why we've
developed or why we're currently
developing parental controls that let
parents not only see how much time their
teens spend on instagram
but set limits
also let me let me just i mean this is a
really important question because if we
have experts saying we need to limit
social media usage which is what the
surgeon general just said yesterday
to help address mental health issues
does that go against the business model
of
instagram or facebook or meta
isn't
isn't your business model to get more
eyeballs for a longer time on social
media isn't that what you're about
senator
if people don't feel good about the time
that they spend on their on our platform
if
if for any other reason people want to
spend less time on our platform i have
to believe that it's better for our
business over the long term but do you
make more money when people spend more
time on your platform or less
senator on average we make more money
when people spend more time on our
platform because we're an advertising
business right so
but you'll but you agree with the
surgeon general that people should limit
their social media usage
my point is they seem to be in direct
contradiction with each other what the
surgeon general is saying we need to
better the health of our young americans
and what your
basic business model proposition is they
seem to be
actually colliding with each other
senator
respectfully i disagree i think the
important thing is to distinguish
between the short term and the long term
over the long run it has to be better
for us as a business for people to feel
good about the time that they spend on
our platform it has to be better for us
as business for parents to not only have
a meaningful amount of control but be
able to exercise that control over how
their teens spend on how much time their
team spent on our platform and so we
take a very long view
on this which we have internal data
relating to mental health and suicide
uh in and um
usage on your platform or or facebook or
meta senator
we do research to make instagram better
and safer and as a parent that's exactly
what i would want i believe we lead the
industry and do more than anyone else
yeah suicide you're not answering my
question do you have let me just answer
it apologize you have internal
data
related to the issue of
teen suicide and usage of your platform
senator i'm not sure exactly understand
your question specifically but yes we do
research and we talk to third-party
experts and academics about difficult
issues like suicide which is inspired
work like not allowing any content that
talks about the methods of suicide
see connecting people who seek out that
type of content with expert-backed
resources and if someone looks like
they're at risk of hurting themselves
proactively reaching to local emergency
services on their behalf not only here
in the u.s but in a number of countries
around the world mr chairman i'm just
one final question um
can i ask very quickly i i looked into a
little bit of this issue of
your announcement on instagram for kids
and
just that phrase kind of
makes me nervous it sounds like a
gateway drug to
more usage
why did you put a pause on that and are
you going to permanently
pause that and do you worry that you're
going to get now kids hooked on more
usage with instagram for kids
senator
the idea was trying to solve a problem
we know that 10 to 12 year olds
are online the average age i believe
when you get a cell phone in this
country is currently 11 or 10.
we know that they want to be on
platforms like instagram and instagram
quite frankly wasn't designed for them
so the idea was to give parents the
option to give their child an
age-appropriate version of instagram
that where they could control not only
how much time that they spent but who
they could interact with and what they
could see it was always going to be
a parent's decision now i personally as
the head of instagram i'm responsible
for instagram and i decided to pause
that project so that we could take more
time to speak to parents to experts and
to policy makers to make sure that we
get it right
thank you mr sherman thanks senator
sullivan senator young
by webex
thank you chairman
uh welcome mr missouri
in ms haugen's testimony she discussed
how instagram generates self-harm and
self-hate especially for vulnerable
groups like teenage girls now i happen
to have
three
young daughters and two teenage
daughters
and
this issue hits home to me but it hits
home to a lot of americans so you're
here today you're the head of instagram
you have an opportunity to tell your
side of the story
and
i do believe that if we're not receiving
some uh constructive actionable and bold
measures uh to deal with what is
popularly believed to be a serious and
significant public health issue
congress will act
because our constituents insist that we
act we've held a lot of hearings now
uh we've done our best to educate
ourselves but frankly
um
since since you run the platform since
you know the technology
since uh you you spend
uh so much time working on on uh these
matters
um you you could really help us if you
don't
we're we're gonna feel an imperative to
act so that's just the reality of it
so with that said with that foundation
laid do you believe there are any
short-term or long-term consequences of
body image or other issues on your
platform
senator i appreciate the question
the research that we have found
shows that many teens use instagram to
get support when suffering from issues
like body image issues
on
for 11 out of 12 issues for teenage
girls and for 12 out of 12
issues like body image
anxiety and depression we found more
teens who were struggling found that
instagram made things better than worse
the one exception was body image for
teenage girls which is why i personally
actually before we even did this
research
started the social comparison team that
research has inspired ideas like take a
break which launched this week and
nudges which we're currently working on
which encourages you to switch topics if
you spend too much time in any one topic
i'm not here to say that there's only
one perfect solution
but just to give an update on what the
research says and what we're doing to
make instagram safer
got it
i'm familiar with nudges i'm somewhat
familiar with behavioral science i know
that's something that can be harnessed
by our tech community
to generate traffic
um
what is engagement based ranking uh mr
mosseri
senator
i appreciate the question i've worked on
ranking and algorithms for years that
term is often used to describe trying to
connect people with content that they
find interesting so what we do when you
open up instagram as we look at all of
the posts from all of the people that
you all the accounts that you follow and
we try and show you the one that you
find most relevant and we try to make
sure to take out anything that might be
against our community guidelines in
order to keep people safe
at a high level that's usually what
people refer to when they say engagement
based ranking to the best of my
knowledge so is there a behavioral bias
for
teenage girls
to
uh to to
look disproportionately at content that
adversely impacts uh their
um
their self-image
not that i know of senator i do think
that it's important that teens
don't
have negative experiences on our
platform i do think it's important that
we try to understand
the issue that you're raising which i
appreciate which is negative
social comparison or body image social
comparison um and we're trying to
understand
how we can best help and support those
who might be struggling
so there is there is no negativity bias
just as adults have a negative news bias
which is why so much of of of the
news and current events coverage online
can be so caustic
and so
uh corrosive to
our public discourse because uh so often
people marinate in in the negative
um there's no similar bias that you have
discovered and i won't hear from one
from any of your internal experts
pertaining to
um
negative self-image
or teenage girls
sorry to interrupt your center senator i
appreciate the question
i think it's important to call out
that social media allows you to connect
with anyone you're interested in
and
in a world where the definition of
beauty here in the united states used to
be very limited and very focused on a
very unrealistic definition of beauty
media social media platforms like
instagram have allowed or not allowed
but have helped
important movements like body positivity
to flourish so that if you're a teenage
girl of color or if you are
a plus size teenage girl you can see
models of color plus size models it has
helped diversify the definitions of
beauty and that's something that we
think is incredibly important
i don't know of any specific bias
to answer your question very directly
but i want to call out that we help
people reach a more diverse
set of not only definitions of beauty
but points of view
and
perspectives do you have behavioral
scientists who work uh internal to
instagram
senator
we have data scientists who try and
understand how people use the platform
in order to make instagram both better
and safer
and they data for they would inform you
i presume but i don't want to presume i
want to get you on the record they
they would be informing you if if
they ever discovered a negativity bias
in the research
or or in the behaviors of of your user
community as it relates to teenage girls
and self-harm or self-hate right
senator i expect my data scientists as i
expect my researchers to keep me abreast
of any important developments with
regards not only to safety but to
instagram and the industry more broadly
thanks senator young thank
you senator lummus
thank you mr chairman
companies like instagram are often
designing technology to maximize the
collection of our data
and subsequently sell visibility into
its users private lives and interests
that's why when a company called signal
bought advertisements designed to show
us the information it collects and sells
about us
those ads were banned by instagram's
parent company
it's the black box of highly secretive
algorithmic systems
the companies like instagram deploy that
operate largely undetected by the user
and which allow them to continue to
operate free of meaningful scrutiny this
is not an open source system
sunlight disinfects and congress must
not scroll past this critical moment
without properly addressing the harms
young people are encountering on these
platforms
mr mosseri thank you for being here
in your testimony you stated that
instagram has
limited advertisers options
for serving ads to people under 18 to
age gender and location
but your testimony neglects to mention
that any similar prohibition on
instagram's own machine learning ad
delivery system
does instagram's machine learning ad
delivery system target ads to children
using factors other than age gender and
location
senator i appreciate the question
there's one ads delivery system both for
instagram and for facebook we only allow
advertisers to target those under 18
based on age gender and location and
overall the system also uses activity
that
teens use
within the app to make sure that ads are
relevant to teens okay so you don't
limit yourselves you
hold yourselves to a lower standard than
your advertisers
senator we do limit ourselves and that
we don't use any off platform data but
we do also use activity in the apps to
make sure that ads are relevant for
instance if i'm not interested in a
specific band because it's another part
of the country or because i don't like
that type of music it doesn't make sense
for me to see that type of ad so mr
chairman i ask unanimous consent to
enter into the record a report from fair
play that shows meta is still using an
a.i delivery system to target ads at
children without exception thank you mr
chairman
um
your head of safety and well-being
vaishnavi j recently stated that any one
piece of content is unlikely to make you
feel good or bad or negative about
yourself it's really when you're viewing
say 20 minutes of that content or
multiple pieces of that content in rapid
succession that may have a negative
impact on how you feel
so to me her statement says that your
company knows the time spent on the
platform increases the likelihood of
real-world negative impacts
so how do you square a business model
that prioritizes user time and
engagement
with knowing there's a direct
correlation between time and harm
senator respectfully
using our platform more will increase
any effect whether it's positive or
negative we try and connect people with
their friends we try to help them
explore their interests we even try to
help them start new businesses but if
people don't feel good about the time
that they spend on our platform that's
something i personally take seriously
and why we build things like daily
limits and while we're currently working
on parental controls that are focused on
time
does instagram make money from ads that
are seen when placed next to
highly viewed and viral but also harmful
content that violates the rules of your
platform
senator we don't allow content that
violates our rules on the platform we
release publicly how effective we are at
removing that content and we receive
revenue based on ads shown okay so is
the money returned to the advertisers
then
senator not that i know of no
um
is it your position that instagram will
always comply
with the laws of the country in which it
operates senator we're going to do our
best to always comply with the law okay
um
will you commit to releasing those
guidelines to members of this committee
senator apologies which guidelines
it would be um guidelines related to how
you comply so let me give you an example
if an authoritarian regime submitted a
lawful request for your platform to
censor political dissidence
would you comply
and if not what are your guidelines on
something like that here's let me give
you some real world examples
if a government
let's say uganda
uh criminalizes homosexuality
and if they the if the government
submitted a lawful request for a data on
users that are members of the lgbt
community would instagram comply
senator
we try and use our best judgment in
order to keep people safe i also believe
that transparency on the specific issue
is incredibly important i will double
check and get back to your office but i
believe we also are public about
incoming requests we get at a high level
so
one of the one of the reasons that i'm
concerned about the fact that this is a
sort of secretive data collection based
on a non-open source uh algorithm
is because it gives you
uh that veil of secrecy people don't
know what information is being collected
about them yet if a if a hostile
government
is able to identify
people like women who are
learning against the law being educated
against the law
or someone who's homosexual
where in a government where
homosexuality
is punishable by death and there are
governments that do this
um
if you turn over that data and it's
collected by artificial intelligence
that artificial intelligence is not
going to discern
that they're putting a human being in
danger
um these the the platform
artificial intelligence
while
when not guided
and not open sourced can be a real
problem
mr chairman thank you i yield back
thanks senator
senator cantwell thank you uh chairman
blumenthal and thank you to you and
senator blackburn for this fabulous
hearing i know we've had great
attendance from members i'm so impressed
by the questions that all our colleagues
have been asking so i hope it will lead
us to some good legislative solutions
and appreciate mr uh
uh masseri is that the right way of
saying it myself that's just great okay
for being here today
obviously a big new day on the job so uh
wanted to ask you specifically
about uh
privacy violations do you believe that
claims of privacy violations
um by kids should go to arbitration i
mean that is do you believe that when
people are signing up for your service
when they're 14 year olds they
understand that they are giving away
their rights when they sign up to your
service senator respectfully i disagree
with the characterization that anyone
gives away their rights when they sign
up for our service i think people
i think privacy is incredibly important
and we do
the best we can and we invest a lot of
resources in making sure we respect
people's privacy so if a child has
suffered harm
of the magnitude and they try to
try to get those
issues addressed do you think they
should be in arbitration
senator i'm not trying to understand the
exact hypothetical but i do believe if a
child is at risk specifically of hurting
themselves
no one of my constituents
was working with a mother uh whose
fourteen-year-old daughter was groomed
by adults on instagram ultimately was
lured into sex trafficking taken across
state lines for prostitution under
instagram's terms of service instagram
can argue that a child's only recourse
against instagram's failure to provide a
safe environment would be an arbitration
with no open court no discovery no judge
no jury no appeal
so i'm asking you what you think about
when real harm is created against
children and what should be the process
senator that story is terrifying
we don't allow
child or human trafficking of any kind
we try to be as public as we can about
how well we do on difficult problems
like that one and we believe
that we should be there should be
industry standards there should be
industry-wide accountability and that
the best way to do that is federal
legislation which is specifically what
i'm proposing today
on this point what what we're trying to
get at is that when users in this case
particularly
young children are signing up for
service
what they're signing up to in a check
mark is that you are signing up to
binding arbitration with the company so
if there's a dispute about something
that happened and yes we've been
considering privacy legislation our
colleagues here have been trying to
protect young children in other ways and
we've certainly found some very
egregious situations of late the only
recourse they have is to go into binding
arbitration with you as a company and
we're saying when there's something as
egregious
as a privacy violation that they should
have other recourse i'm just simply
asking you whether you believe they
should have other recourse
senator i appreciate the question i
believe the most responsible approach in
this area more broadly not only for
privacy but for safety is federal
regulation here in the u.s
do you think everybody has to go through
you or one of your other software
ask companies to get redress
do you think that the only redress
consumers should have is through binding
arbitration with a company senator i
believe that whatever the law states
should apply to all
companies like ours equally i'm asking
you what you think as a company
senator i'm not familiar with this
position okay i'm going to ask you for
the record and then that way you'll get
a little more time and you can consider
it but these are serious issues
about the fact that serious issues are
happening to children and the only
redress they have is to go into binding
arbitration with you and i think wow
that might be like hey i don't like your
service or something happened or you
overcharged me or this happened that
might be great for binding arbitration
but serious harm to people i don't think
should be sent to binding arbitration
okay back to the advertising question if
we could for a second my colleagues have
done a really good job at
um asking about this but
um
obviously
people have been talking about the
ability to make
money off of specific content whether in
the facebook
uh that was described as potential reach
metric i think we've been talking about
that right people have been discussing
that are you aware of inaccuracies in
the potential reach metric
senator
i'm not aware of any specific
inaccuracies but we do our best
we can to make sure advertisers
understand reach before they spend using
tools like that do you think that
there's hate speech that's that's uh not
taken down by
um
in in that's included in that would you
agree that like informing advertisers in
the public how much hate speech
there is or if it's taken down or not
taken down
senator respectfully i believe the
potential reach
tool allows you to get a sense of how
many people you will reach which is
different than how much content on hate
speech content specifically in our
community standards enforcement report
you can see that i believe three and ten
thousand pieces of content seen
qualifies hate speech by our definition
do you think that advertising can be
inaccurate or misleading based on
certain metrics
senator
as an advertising business i believe
it's in our interest to be as accurate
as possible i think whenever we make
mistakes we know that undermines our
credibility and advertising businesses
are based on trust
right and they're also based on being
truthful to your advertisers and so what
i'm getting at is miss haugen came to
testify before the committee she's
saying that facebook purposely made
decision to keep up metrics that drove
more traffic
even though she knew that they that the
company knew that it included things
that were related to hate speech that
that certainly motivated more traffic
and when presented with the information
the company and various members of the
company decided to continue using that
metric and so what i'm saying there
could be instances where instagram has
also
continued to have advertisers not fully
aware so do you believe advertisers
should be aware if there was any content
that was related to hate speech that
they should be aware
that that that a metric that they
should be aware of what content they're
being served with
senator i believe advertisers should
have access to data about how much hate
speech there's on the platform just like
everyone should have access to that kind
of data i'm not i don't believe
i should never i'm not familiar with
what you're specifically referencing
with regard to her testimony but it
doesn't line up with any of my
experience during my 13 years here at
the company that we would intentionally
mislead advertisers that would be a
gross violation of trust and it would
inevitably come out and undermine our
credibility
so you don't think there's any deceptive
practices with advertisers that you're
involved in in instagram
senator
not only do i not believe that i think
that would be do you think advertisers
know everything about your algorithm and
what it is attached to and giving them
page views and information senator i
believe
deeply in transparency i've spent an
immense amount of time over the years
not only trying to be transparent about
how our algorithms work but also
investing in making sure we're
transparent about how much problematic
content is on the platform and i believe
you can see that in a community
standards report and i believe other
companies like snapchat tick tock and
youtube should do the same i see my time
is way over mr chairman but i'm going to
ask you questions for the record on this
as well because the point is if
companies are involved in deceptive
practices with advertisers
and they haven't told them how they're
artificially increasing their traffic
and it's related to to something that
the advertisers aren't aware of that is
a deceptive practice so thank you mr
chairman
thank you senator campbell thanks for
your excellent work on this issue and
your help and support
in these hearings senator cruz
thank you mr chairman mr masari welcome
thank you for being here thank you for
testifying before the committee and
thank you for being here in person
um
as you are aware
i and many members of this committee
have had significant concerns
uh about instagram's practices and
facebook's practices and big tech more
broadly
in september 2021
the wall street journal published a
series of investigative articles titled
the facebook files
and as you know the wall street journal
reported
that
researchers inside of instagram found
that 32 percent of teen girls using the
product
felt that instagram made them feel bad
about their bodies
the wall street journal further reported
that 13 percent of british users
and 6 percent of american users
trace their desire to kill themselves
to instagram
now those are deeply
troubling conclusions
are you familiar with the research that
was cited by the wall street journal
senator yes but if we're going to have a
conversation about the research i think
we need to be clear about what it
actually says
it actually showed that one out of three
girls who suffer from body image issues
find that instagram makes things worse
and that came from a slide with 23 other
statistics where more teens found that
instagram made things better now we have
doesn't mean it's not serious and on
suicide it was actually
and any one life lost to suicide is an
immense tragedy but on suicide it was
one percent who traced their thoughts
back to instagram and i think it's
important that we're clear about what
the research says
so i'm glad to see that we found some
common ground uh you just said twice
there it's important for us to be clear
what the research said i agree at prior
hearings i've asked your colleagues
repeatedly
for copies of the research and to my
knowledge you have refused to produce it
will you commit now to produce the
research to this committee so we can as
you just said be clear about what the
research says
senator
i really appreciate this question
because it's incredibly important that
we're transparent about research
i can commit personally to doing all i
can to release the data behind the
research the two challenges that i need
to let you know of are one
privacy in certain cases and two and
often cases we do not have the data
anymore due to our data retention
policies but given that i can also
commit to you that we will provide
meaningful access to data to third-party
researchers outside the company so that
they can draw their own conclusions and
design their own studies to understand
the effects of
not only instagram but facebook on
well-being and i think other companies
should do the same in what format was
this research communicated to you you
just referenced a slide that had bullet
points i would love to see that slide
uh you you criticize this committee for
not appreciating the full contents of
the research when you haven't given us
the research
in what form
did this research come to you was it a
powerpoint presentation what how was it
memorialized
and presented to you
senator there are two forms that the
research comes in i believe the most
important is the data because that
allows any researcher and i'm committed
to making sure
external researchers outside the company
can do research and have access to that
to draw their own conclusions and then
presentations like powerpoint slides
in the specific of that slide we've
actually made that slide public but i
believe the most important thing over
time is that we provide regular access
to meaningful data about social media
usage across the entire industry
to
academics and experts to design their
own studies and draw their own
conclusions and that will take time
because many of these studies can often
take years but it's something i am
personally
very committed to
now when you saw your own study
finding a significant percentage of
girls
uh
reported that
instagram caused them to think about
killing themselves
were you concerned by by that that
finding
senator
just to clarify i believe the study said
they traced their thoughts but yes
i'm concerned about anybody who feels
worse about themselves after using the
platform and certainly anyone any one
individual because we're talking about
people here not numbers
that has any suicidal thoughts well
let's talk about numbers for a second
did instagram do anything to quantify
how many teenage girls have killed
themselves because of your product
senator
we do research and talk to third party
experts about not only suicide but
self-harm on a regular basis and that
research has inspired much of our work
to not only make sure that we have very
clear policies so did you quantify it or
not
senator i'm not sure exactly what you
would mean by quantifying the situation
but you do research to
estimate to count
how many teenage girls have taken their
lives because of your product
senator
we do research to understand problems
and identify solutions in the case of
suicide to make sure we take down
suicide-related content from the
platform to connect those seeking out
this type of content with expert-backed
resources
and to connect anyone who looks like
they're a threat of hurting themselves
with local emergency services how did
you change your policies as a result of
this research
to protect young girls senator i
appreciate the question
we use research to not only change our
policies but to change our product on a
regular basis with regards to bullying
the research has inspired things like
restrict which allow you to protect
yourself from someone who's harassing
you without them knowing and limits
because we learned that teens struggle
during moments of transition
with suicide and self-injury we learned
that we need to be incredibly careful
because often teens suffering from these
really difficult issues
use instagram to find support and we
need to make sure that they can find
that support and talk about recovery
while making sure
big tech
loves to use grand eloquent phrases
about
bringing people together but the simple
reality and why so many americans
distrust big tech
is you make money
the more people are on your product the
more people are engaged in viewing
conduct even if the content that is
harmful to them even if they're viewing
every eyeball you're making money
and
when your colleagues have been asked the
same question as a result of this
research what policies did you change
this committee has been unable to get a
straight answer to that question about
what is different
and i think the reason for that is if
you change policies to reduce the
eyeballs you'd make less money is is is
why is that inference not correct
senator
if people don't feel safe on our
platform
if people don't feel good about the time
that they spend on our platform over
time they're going to use other services
competition has never been fiercer
particularly here in the states with
youtube and tick tock and snapchat and
so i have to believe that over the long
run
it's not only incredibly important that
we keep people safe but we make sure
people feel good about the time that
they spend on our platform so my time
has expired but i want to make sure i
understand the commitment you made to
this committee as i understand it you
have committed to providing this
committee
with the raw data from the research you
did on on users of your product and in
particular body image issues and and
tendencies toward suicide
and and also with the powerpoint
presentations that memorialize that raw
data is that correct that you will
provide them to this committee senator
what i'm committing to you is to do
everything i can do
to release you you can do that
is there a reason you can't do what i
just said senator the challenge on the
data which i think is the most important
thing is that in many cases we no longer
have it how about the powerpoint
presentations will you give us the
powerpoint presentations senator i think
the most responsible thing to do is to
provide access to data to external
researchers outside the company we'd
like both
is there a reason you're hiding the
powerpoint presentations you said you
wanted maximum transparency maximum
transparency
would be show us the presentations that
were prepared for you presumably you had
some reason to trust them because they
were prepared for your consumption
senator
i believe you already have the
presentations which is why we're focused
on the data we think that
any researcher should be able to draw
their own conclusions based on the raw
data that is the most important and the
most knowledgeable part of the process
unfortunately much of that data we no
longer have due to data retention
policies which is why i'm very committed
to making sure that we can allow access
to meaningful engagement data to
researchers outside the company in the
future to focus specifically
on the effects of social media and
well-being and i'm calling for the rest
of the industry to do the same so your
commitment is to provide all of the data
that you have and the powerpoint
presentation summarizing it senator
my commitment is to provide meaningful
access to data based on what researchers
request
because i think that is the most
responsible thing for us to do over the
long run okay we're requesting right now
senator
for to do a study on the effects of
well-being
oh sorry the effects of social media on
well-being you'd have to design that
study so
i would like to talk to
you i mean we've worked with pew we've
worked with harvard we've worked with
other organizations around the world i
would like to talk to the researchers
and understand what specific data they
would like access to i can't just
provide all data that we have that's an
untenable thing to do physically the
data that was the basis for the study
quoted in the wall street journal report
senator that's the data i'm asking about
and
presentations that summarized the
conclusions of that senator i would love
to provide that data i'm
personally working on trying to find out
if there's any way we can provide it in
a privacy safe way in a way where we
still have it and i think that's because
i think that's important i've been
working on that i don't want to over
promise and under deliver here which is
why i'm more focused on how we make sure
researchers have access to data going
forward
thanks senator cruz i i just want to say
uh mr massari because you and i have
discussed this point
the data sets are not enough
this answer is
in my view just completely
unsatisfactory we want the studies
we want the research we want the surveys
the whistleblower has
disclosed a lot of it
and the answer that you've given
very respectfully
simply
won't get it
it's in your files if it was destroyed
we want to know about
that
too
but
information
is absolutely the coin of the realm when
we go about
advising legislation and i must say
there's a
kind of disconnect here
senator sullivan asked you
about
content relating to
suicidal or self-harm
i think i'm quoting almost directly and
you said there isn't any
well we have a team
account
with all the protections on the filters
we searched quote slit risk
and the results
i don't feel i can describe in this
hearing room
they are so graphic
that's within the past couple of days
i described to you
an account that
looked at
in effect eating disorders
and attracted the same deluge
of
self-harm and
anorexia coaches
so
i just feel
that there is a kind of
real
lack of connection to the reality of
what's there in the testimony that
you're giving today which makes it hard
for us to
have you as a partner and maybe
we need to
have some kind of compulsory process you
know senator cruz and i don't always
don't always agree
but on this point on the need for
information i think
you've heard here
the bipartisan call for
a reality check and for action and the
fact that
this content continues to exist
on the site despite your denials
i think um
really is hard to accept
you know um instagram suggested as a
solution here to nudge
teens
i don't know whether your kids have
reached the teen age yet
takes more than a nudge
to move teens i
am well beyond the teenage years in my
four children
but
if you said to a teen who
was
on instagram
fixated on eating disorders why don't
you try
snorkeling in the bahamas
that nudge just won't work
and
instagram has a real asymmetric power
here it drives teens
in a certain direction
and then
[Music]
makes it very difficult
for
the teen once
in a dark place to
find light again and to get out of it
so
my question to you is
don't we need
enforceable standards set by
an independent authority not an industry
body
objective independent researchers with
full access to your algorithms will you
commit to support
full disclosure of your algorithms and
a commitment to an independent authority
senator directly we're very aligned we
agree on the transparent the important
of transparency not only of how ranking
works well then you would make available
all of the studies
like the ones that francis haugen
presented to us when she was here
senator i'm confident that we are more
transparent than any other tech industry
company in the industry that's a pretty
low bar mr missouri
that's like you're in
the gutter forgive me in terms of
transparency because
they committed
to make available
their algorithms but only
after we pressed them to do it and we
still
are awaiting full compliance
senator we've been publishing research
for years we're going to publish over
100 things this year alone
i believe that there's an immense amount
of data in our quarterly reports
i believe that we're going to start
having them audited by ernst young
starting this quarter i believe that our
ads library provides more transparency
and advertising than any other
advertising business in any industry
tech or otherwise
yes i believe there's more to do
yes i believe in federal legislation
yes i believe that policymakers should
be actively involved in that
and i'm looking forward to having our
teams work with yours on shaping exactly
what that looks like will you support
the earn it act
senator directionally we believe
strongly in transparency and
accountability i'm unfortunately not
familiar with every provision in that
act but more than happy to have our team
work with you on that
if you believe what you've testified
here you would say yes i support the
internet senator
respectfully i don't think would be
appropriately appropriate for me to
commit to something that i haven't read
in full but i really do want our team to
work with yours as i've said we're
calling for industry-wide regulation we
believe it's incredibly important
it's why we're having this hearing today
it's why i appreciate these questions
even though they're difficult at times
because we believe there's nothing more
important than keeping teens safe online
and we believe we need to come together
into you you support
prohibitions bans
on advertising and marketing teens for
products that are illegal
for them to consume
senator i believe we already prohibit
that so in the case of under 18 year
olds we don't provide we don't allow ads
for
um because we don't provide we don't
allow ads for tobacco to any age but we
don't allow ads for things like gambling
for under 18 we don't allow ads for
alcohol for under 21. would you support
legally enforceable prohibitions where
you can be held
liable
senator yes we support industry
standards and accountability and i
believe part of those industry standards
as i call out in my testimony include
age-appropriate design which will
inevitably include
content rules about what is appropriate
if you host
child sexual abuse material
should the victims be able to sue you
senator
child exploitation is an incredibly
serious issue issue
i believe an earlier senator mentioned
how we could we collaborated with netmec
on this i believe that we're going to
continue to invest
more than anyone else on this space and
i believe that federal regulation is the
best form of accountability with
enforcement to your point before
i'm going to turn to senator blackburn i
have a few more
questions if we have time to get to
yes and in the question about necmec i
wanted to know if you reported
traffickers
and i think that that is something
important to do you need to come back to
us on that also you mentioned
uh referring children to local
authorities you need to let us know how
many are we talking about is it in the
hundreds thousands give us those numbers
so that we have that data
also i'd like to know how long you hold
the data
on your research you've mentioned you
can't give us the data and then you say
well you may not have some of this data
we need to know how long you're holding
this data on miners
those children that you're data mining
and i was glad to hear you admit that
you all are a big advertising business i
thought that that was helpful to our
discussion
you mentioned in response to senator
lee's question that you hoped you did
not sound callous when we were talking
about children
that take their life or that have
lifelong problems because of what they
have encountered on instagram
and sir i have to tell you you did sound
callous
because every single life matters
every life matters
and um
this is why we need this research
um
i thought it's also interesting you
basically give teen girls no recourse
if they get into a a dark spot
using instagram but we've got a lot of
parents that come to us this is why
we're doing these hearings and they're
concerned
about how their children are going to be
affected for the rest of their life and
i asked you yesterday when we talked if
you ever talked to these parents whose
children have taken their life
or have ended up
having to have mental health
services
because of what they've incurred you
said yes you do so i want to give you
one minute
i speak to parents
who are struggling
their children have attempted suicide or
maybe some of them
have taken their life so take the next
minute and speak directly
to these parents because as i told you
yesterday i've talked to a lot of
parents they've never heard one word
from instagram or facebook or meta
and they are struggling with this
uh senator cantwell
brought this up to you so sir the next
60 seconds the floor is yours you can
have longer than a minute if you like
speak to these parents because we're not
talking to people
that have ever had any kind of response
from instagram and you have broken these
children's lives
and you have broken these parents heart
flour's yours have at it
thank you senator
senator i'm a father of three
to any parent
who's
lost a child or even had a child hurt
themselves i can't
begin to imagine what that would be like
for one of my three boys
as the head of instagram it's my
responsibility to do all i can
to keep people
safe i've been committed to that for
years
and i'm going to continue to do so
whether or not we invest more than every
other company or not
doesn't really matter for any individual
if if any individual harms themselves or
as a negative experience on our platform
that's something that i take incredibly
seriously
now i i know i've talked a lot about
parental controls
as i've said
i really do believe that a parent knows
what's best for their child or a
guardian
but i also know that a lot of parents
are busy
i've got three kids and i have a lot of
support i can't imagine what it would be
like to have four kids or three kids and
be a single parent or working two jobs
and so i don't want to rely
on parental controls i think it's
incredibly important
that the experience is safe
and appropriate for your age no matter
what it is 13 15 17.
but if you have the time
and the interest i also think as a
parent you have the right to be able to
understand what your kids are doing
online and you should have control to
shape that experience into what's best
for them
and if you don't have time that's okay
too it's my responsibility to do all i
can to help not only keep
young people safe on our platform but
anybody uses our platform
mr missouri we are telling you
children
have
inflicted self-harm
they are getting information that is
destroying their young lives
and we are asking you
have some empathy
and take some
responsibility and it seems as if you
just can't
get on that path
so we're going to continue to work on
this issue
i wish that your response had been a
more empathetic response
thanks senator blackburn uh i just have
one more question and i think we're
going to make the five o'clock deadline
uh we want to be respectful of your time
um
i understand that it's important to have
your internal
discussions and debate as any company
must
but these studies and research
are
really important for parents to make
decisions
and
i'm reminded of
actually some work i did when i was
state attorney general in connecticut we
were one of the first states
with the help of
a company in connecticut named legos
to require
warnings about small parts
on
toys which i urge the legislature to do
as state attorney general then i fought
the industry when it challenged
that labeling
and we won
against challenges based on the commerce
clause and other constitutional claims
and the supreme court denied certiorari
and then
the industry decided it wanted a federal
standard because it didn't want to deal
with state by state
requirements
well the point was
that the law required companies to
disclose risk
it encouraged them to compete over
values
that were positive and that promoted
safety
and that's the kind of competition that
we need in
your industry as senator kobachar
mentioned earlier we've been working on
anti-trust measures to promote more
competitions so that maybe there will be
some on
safety
but disclosure
the disinfectant of sunlight
is so important so
my question to you is would instagram
support
legal requirements
on social media platforms to provide
public disclosures about the risks of
harms the risk of harms in
content
senator
i would support
federal legislation around the
transparency of data
around the access to data from
researchers and around the prevalence of
content problems on the platform i think
all of those are important ways that
parents or anyone really can get a sense
for
what a platform is doing and what its
effects on people are
i believe deeply that transparency is
important which is why
i'm confident we're going to continue
to lead the industry on being incredibly
transparent about what happens on our
platform
well you've said
repeatedly that you're in favor of
one goal or another directionally
and
i find that
term
really incomplete when it isn't
accompanied by specific commitments a
yes or a no
and we're going to move forward on this
committee directionally with specifics
the
kinds of baby steps
that you've suggested so far very
respectfully are
underwhelming
a nudge
a break
that ain't gonna
save kids from the addictive effects
and there's no question there are
addictive effects
of
your platform and i think you will sense
on this committee pretty strong
determination
to do something well beyond what you've
indicated you have in mind and that's
the reason that
um
i think self-policing based on trust is
no longer a viable solution so we thank
you for being here today
we're going to continue
the effort to develop legislation many
of us senator markey
senator thune
senator klobuchar myself
working with senator blackburn who's
been a great partner in this effort
this hearing
record will remain open for two weeks if
you feel you want to supplement
any of your answers my colleagues who
would like to submit questions for the
record
should do so by december 22nd
and we ask that your responses be
returned to the committee as quickly as
possible and okay
more than two weeks after receipt
that concludes today's hearing thank you
very much for being here
and
i think we're pretty much on time thank
you thank you chairman boomenthal thank
you ranking member blackburn i
appreciate your time thank you
you